la boutique je rêvais d'être pilote et
contrairement à ce qu'on peut à ce que
laisse supposer la photo c'est pas
l'idée de côtoyer des hôtesses de l'air
il m'intéressait le plus mais réellement
l'art du pilotage
parce que je voyais passer des avions
dans le ciel valaisan je rêvais qu'un
jour je pourrai prendre place terre
comment alors j'ai travaillé dur pendant
les études à côté de mes études au
pouvoir le pays mon premier brevet de
pilote
mais lorsque j'ai enfin pu lâcher du
regard des instruments de bord ce qui
m'a le plus fasciné c'est le changement
de perspective qu'on a sur notre
environnement
les détails font place à une vue
d'ensemble c'est comme une espèce de
prise de recul forcé par rapport à son
environnement
alors qu'on observait alors des
phénomènes qu'on voit pas ce qu'il en
reste sur le plancher des vaches
on peut imaginer par exemple l'odeur des
bouchons sur les autoroutes
on peut imaginer les traces laissées par
les incendies dans le feu dans ton nos
forêts on peut imaginer les éboulements
dans les montagnes ou alors de recul
impressions des glaciers ces dernières
années et lorsqu'on parle finalement
c'est bien dommage que cette cette
perspective prise de parts respectives
des papes plus accessible n'est pas plus
utilisé au mieux faire face aux
problématiques auxquelles nous sommes
confrontés à lorsqu'on parle de
perspectives aérienne d'imagés aériennes
on pense tout de suite à google maps de
satellites
il faut se rappeler que les satellites
ne sont pas d'une très très grande
résolution et en particulier dans
certaines parties du monstre que leurs
images peuvent être polluée par des
nuages et que finalement ces images
datent souvent de plusieurs mois voire
de plusieurs années
c'est donc en fait pour pouvoir donner
une d'inspecter aérienne de qualité à
haute résolution et récente qu'on a créé
notre start up en 2010 on y fabrique ces
petits drones qui pèse moins d'un kilo
qui voit semble à déjouer mais qui
permettent en fait à n'importe qui
n'importe où dans le monde de prendre
des descentes end de clichés de faste
qui va errer end un site et j'insiste
sur le fait que ces petits drones sont
en fait des systèmes complètement
autonome ils sont équipés d'un auto
pilot un gps
la télécommande est remplacé par un
ordinateur il suffit de dessiner la
jauge de longue date au quartier pour
ensuite élancé dans le ciel ils vont
accomplir nos missions et revenir
atterrir en douceur auquel l'opérateur
fait l'intéressant c'est quand on prend
une série de clichés de façon
systématique un site on peut utiliser la
magie du traitement d'image trois
ordinateurs pour trion ville et des
millions de points entre plusieurs
paires d'image est localisée de façon
super précise dans l'espace c'est ce
qu'on appelle la photo gallery et j'ai
vraiment vous présenter trois domaines
qui aurait connu une révolution ces
dernières années grâce à cette
technologie donne plus photogrammétrie
le premier d'entre eux c'est la
géomatique géomètres ont besoin de
pouvoir mesurer de façon très précise
dans l'espace un certain nombre de
points mais aussi de pouvoir créer des
cartes et des cartes en trois dimensions
puisqu'ils ont besoin de dessiner des
cours de niveau
ils ont besoin d'estimé des volumes par
exemple sur les sites de construction
autant d dans des carrières et bien
maintenant les joueurs mais plutôt que
d'utiliser des appareils classiques
comme les théodoric de gps de précision
et d'arpenter ainsi qu'ils peuvent
utiliser des drones pour mesurer des
millions de kwh en entendre parler jeu
mais ne sont pas des gens faciles à
convaincre il faut d'abord leur montrer
que le nouveau système est d'autant plus
que l'ancien et c'est ce que cous cette
course est un profit de terrain on
compare les deux classiques par gps de
patienter en rouge et le la sortie du
drone et on voit finalement que le drone
est autant précisent puisque la courbe
du profil du terrain suis bien heureux
mais conclut elle donne beaucoup plus
d'informations puisque tous les points
terminer un centre aussi
exemple une meilleure représentation de
la réalité et ce qui est génial à
quiberon
c'est que en prenant toutes ces images
en les mettant ensemble de façon
automatique on peut produire un modèle
tridimensionnel textures et
l'environnement si on voit ainsi dans
des battles qui a fait l'objet d'une
étude d'implantation d'une usine de
traitement des eaux
hélas lors quasiment impossible
d'envoyer des géomètres avec des moyens
classiques dans le terrain pour tout
mesurer si les drones avec les noix les
équipes de quelques personnes a pu le
faire en quelques jours et je la vends
trouvé 40 km avec des centaines de
millions points assez activement à
l'heure actuelle on estime environ un
cadre le nombre de bureaux de géomètre à
travers le monde
il s'est déjà équipée amoureuse de
cartographie un autre challenge lequel
notre société doit faire face
c'est celui de nourrir une population
grandissante tout en utilisant des
territoires limité en plus nombreux et
là aussi on voit de plus en plus
d'agriculteurs utiliser ces petits
drones dans ce cas là ils sont équipés
de capteurs infrarouge capable d'estimer
le taux de chlorophylle dans les landes
et données qui sont révoltés en faisant
survoler les gens de façon régulière
sont aussi traités par ordinateur
comprenant des cartes à nouveau mais les
cartes en fausses couleurs
j'écarte d'index qui permettent de
localiser de façon précise les endroits
où les plantes ont subi un stress plus
importants et ces quatre sont très
utiles pour ensuite être chargées à bord
d amnésie détracteurs qui m'ont ne sais
pas j'ai de plus en plus aussi équipés
de gps est automatique
en tout cas capable de moduler le taux
de grève ils injectent dans les chambres
qui font le passage et au final les sols
sont moins pollué et leur productivité
d'être moins un minerai dans le domaine
des sciences de l'environnement
les chercheurs utilisent aussi le plus
en plus souvent cette nouvelle
technologie aux mesures et d'étonner au
moment exact
besoin avec une précision une résolution
bien meilleurs que ceux des satellites
dans les magasins les chercheurs ont
utilisé des drones pour modéliser
l'évolution des glaciers il faut savoir
que c'est pas rien puisque les glaciers
les glaciers de l'himalaya en fait sans
la source des dix plus grandes rivières
d'asie dont dépend un cinquième de la
population mondiale alors en faisant des
modèles 3d de ces glaciers régulière
donc grâce à ces petits drôles ils ont
pu modéliser le masque la sienne et donc
comme ça mieux prédire l'évolution leur
évolution en fonction du climat dans
l'étude de l'érosion du littoral et la
ville et les drones sont aussi très
utiles puisqu'ils permettent de créer
des cartes avec une précision incroyable
et surtout de différentes époques
superposables ici on voit un quart en
irlande du nord où la route et le char
qui ont été avalés par amen en seulement
trois ans les drones ont permis de
mettre en évidence l géomatique
l'agriculture les sciences de
l'environnement sont seulement trois
domaines où les drones de cartographie
la perspective de ces renards onglet la
façon de travailler de comprendre notre
environnement
en fait il en existe bien d'autres on
peut imaginer l'inscription des ouvrages
d'art c'est beaucoup plus facile à la
baisse
la lutte contre les incendies
l'archéologie l'aide humanitaire m comme
ici offrit aux philippines ou après le
passage du typhon m
on a utilisé des drones pour donner les
cartes à jour de montrer l'étendue des
dégâts relations locales et les aider à
reconstruire ensuite leur village
lorsqu'un volcan entre en éruption c'est
beaucoup plus facile d'utiliser un drôle
vous faire la cartographie des coulées
de lave que d'envoyer un pilote qui
risque et de même sa vie de sa vie en
péril si c'est un exemple en haïti en
2014 qui a finalement les aider à
qualifier le seul et même dans le
domaine de l'exploration spatiale
les drôles d'art est aussi de créer des
modèles de sol martien pour ensuite
faciliter la mise au point des robots
d'exploration
vous l'aurez compris des domaines les
possibilités de maître d'application des
drones alsace
ils sont absolument illimité et à dire
qu'on les avait pas tous anticipé
lorsqu'on a commencé notre stable
les utilisateurs en fait lancé pour nous
à tel point que nous avons vendu des
milliers le drôle dans plus d'une
centaine de pays à travers le monde et
nous ne sommes pas les seuls puisque le
marché des petites bourdes à usage civil
représente déjà maintenant 1 25 milliard
de francs suisses et l'évolution de ce
marché là sur les analystes parient sur
une croissance assez impressionnant de
ces prochaines années
et si on se trouve maintenant dans la
ligue
lorsque les technologies et la
législation permettront de faire
cohabiter les différents utilisateurs de
l'espace aérien de classement
intéressant intelligence lorsque la
démonstration a été faite de ces petits
systèmes représente un danger bien
moindre que la plupart des moyens de
transport traditionnel et lorsque un
système rodé mis au point où garantir la
sauvegarde de la vie privée eh bien les
rôles vont devenir encore bien plus
utile est omniprésent dans nos vies ils
commenceront par nous livrer des paquets
de façon bien plus rapide et bien moins
polluantes qu'avec les moyens
traditionnels
il a moins de secours dans la ville par
exemple
avant même que les angles ans le temps
de quitter l'hôpital et vendront aussi à
très haute altitude dans la stratosphère
au servir de moyen de communication à
l'observation de la nati ils finiront
sans doute par révolutionner notre
mobilité opaline ces petits véhicules
est effectif on nous transporter à
travers un espace aérien complètement
subjugué par le chemin le plus court et
sans plus et en évitant aussi les
bouchons
imaginez un monde on aurait vu le temps
d'investir des milliards dans la
construction et l'entretien les
infrastructures routières ou l'espace au
sol seraient libérés des voies de
circulation et où finalement le temps du
voyage deviendrait enfin une expérience
en définissant l'accès à la troisième
dimension totalement seulement
bouleversé de vives et autres passants
de déplacés et va aussi donner à chaque
test sur notre monde et moi je vais
enfin pouvoir retourner dans le cockpit
sauf que l'avion sera complètement
pratique